thanks guys after five days of
exhilarating chest it is finally time to
Crown our 2023 super bad rapid and Blitz
Champion we are joined by Adam
lamentovich the CEO of Superbad Poland
and Michael kodarkovski the executive
director of the grand Chester Michael
I'm going to give you the first word
thank you Christian yes last round was
to the wire and we are very happy that
Magnus Carlson who is number one world
chess player and five-time World
Champion uh one second lack of the grand
chess tour here in Warsaw and I would
like to congratulate Magnus on this
achievement and once again it's it was
thrilling uh event and we're looking
forward to see Magnus in zagrip in the
third leg and he actually has good good
memories about Zagreb most likely he
will be looking forward to make third
third
as well after 2019 and 2020 to 2022 and
again congratulations to Magnus and
congratulations to everyone who were
watching and to all chess community and
of course I would like to thank our
sponsors from superbed here and looking
forward to Third Leg in Zagreb
Adam
please present the trophy to our
champion Magnus Magnus uh great congrats
uh the the last game was really really
very exciting and and the whole
tournament and and really thanks for uh
joining us here and I hope Poland will
bring only warm and good memories to you
um it was a great event uh definitely
looking forward for the next year and
inviting you all to uh to Zagreb as
Michael already said so thanks a lot and
really a great great job and great
achievement again you know thanks man
thank you
and we will pass this to Magnus Magnus
first of all uh tell us your initial
thoughts and your initial feelings
everybody's hearts are pounding right
now how about yours yeah for sure
um
I I could it's it's one of those things
you know when you can feel your energy
sleeping like a little bit when a day
goes like at the start I was playing
with more flow and it was was easier
um and then with three rounds to go I
could feel or I could already like feel
in the fifth six games that I was not
feeling as energetic anymore and then I
was like hoping like
uh
I was already like starting to think
about the last game
um like I really I was really hoping
that I wouldn't have to
get a result in that game but uh to do
less credit like he kept going and even
in the last game uh I think he made a
poor opening choice because these
um dubious lines that's really my
territory so I generally like that's
that's the stuff I actually actually
know but like he dug in after that and
he played extremely well uh and uh I
really had to fight so hard like of
course A lot of it was self-inflicted
but still like if he if he doesn't play
as well as he as he did like in the in
the last three four games this there
wouldn't have been a thrilling
conclusion but you know happy to come
out on top of course after the second
day a lot of people were writing you off
you were trailing behind by quite a few
points why did you tell yourself at that
point to get yourself back in the
tournament
Jersey or like I played a few Blitz
Games online and I was doing well and I
I just needed one when really uh and
after that I thought
um I mean already on the third day I was
feeling like
uh I was feeling in normal shape so I
thought
um
mainly I just thought that's that's good
I can actually play chess and whether
I'd be able to compete for a tournament
Victory I didn't think about at that
point because it was just
um too early and not realistic and I
mean even with um
even with plus 10 and uh let's see it
was still close so
um but uh but yeah I'm very very happy
happy of course and with the tournament
like not training all the time was kind
of um uh was was not so was not so bad
it meant that I I didn't have any reason
to think about the tournament standings
that I could just play did you relax uh
once you took the lead
um yeah not really
I'm going to the last day I sort of felt
that if I have a good day I'll win
um
since I thought for do that there will
be extra pressure and it wouldn't be so
so easy but I wouldn't necessarily I I
would say I was pretty relaxed the first
few rounds but that was more of like
being being in decent shape and
playing playing well rather than leading
and finally you have so many supporters
around the world and here in Poland as
well your final message to them and your
coach perhaps as well your family tell
us a bit about that
yeah I mean obviously thanks all for for
following and uh it's uh nice to to show
that my uh
retirement only lasted a couple of days
Magnus congratulations you are the 2023
Superbad rapid and Blitz champion thank
you thank you guys for the final time
back to you in the studio in St Louis
thank you